STAY TUNED, SHE IS UP IN JUST A
MINUTE.
THE FIRST NIGHT, AND IT WAS AN
ACT REALLY OF WANT AND CRUELTY
COMMITTED AGAINST DEFENSELESS
TELEVISION VIEWERS.
LAST NIGHT, SEEN AND SUBJECTED
TO TINY AUDIENCE TO WHAT IT
DESCRIBED AS A CLIMATE CHANGE
TOWN HALL.
THE THING WENT ON FOR SEVEN
HOURS.
THAT'S A LONG TIME.
IN FACT, THAT SO LONG THAT
CLIMATE PRODUCTIONS MADE THAT
THE START OF THE EVENING COULD
HAVE BEEN PROVEN WRONG BY THE
END.
AN ENTIRE SPECIES OF POLAR BEAR
MIGHT HAVE BECOME EXTINCT BY THE
THIRD COMMERCIAL BREAK.
THAT'S A LONG TIME.
AND YET IN THE NAME OF SCIENCE,
HUGH HARDY SOULS CENTER TO WATCH
THE ENTIRE THING.
WE CAN'T SAY WITH CERTAINTY WHAT
HAPPENED TO THEM BUT AT LEAST
ONE OF THEM LAPSED INTO TOTAL
UNCONSCIOUSNESS.
WATCH THIS.
>> ENOUGH OF HAVING THE OIL
INDUSTRY AND FOSSIL FUEL
INDUSTRY IT RIGHT ALL OF OUR
LAWS IN THIS AREA.
NO MORE.
>> Tucker: HE WAS THE LUCKY
ONE.
IF HE WAS SLEEPING DEEPLY
ENOUGH, HE MIGHT'VE MISSED CNN
ASKING JULIAN CASTRO WHAT HIS
ADMINISTRATION WOULD DO TO FIGHT
QUOTE ENVIRONMENTAL RACISM.
WE ARE NOT MAKING THAT OUT.
BUT THAT'S JUST THE TIP OF THE
RAPIDLY MELTING ICEBERG.
LAST IT WAS REALLY AN EXERCISE
IN SWEATY MORAL POSTURING.
AT TIMES, THE EVENING BECAME SO
STRIDENT THAT EVEN THE
CANDIDATES ON STAGE CAN KEEP UP
WITH IT ALL.
CORY BOOKER FOR EXAMPLE, HE
TRIED TO REASSURE VIEWERS THAT
DEMOCRATS DON'T REALLY WANT TO
TAKE PEOPLES MEET AWAY,
APPARENTLY THEY HAD FORGOTTEN
THAT KAMALA HARRIS HAD JUST
CALLED FOR THAT.
>> I HEAR ABOUT ALL THE TIME.
BOOKER WANTS TO TAKE AWAY YOUR
HAMBURGER.
WELL, THAT IS THE KIND OF WHY
AND FEARMONGERING THAT THEY
SPREAD OUT THERE THAT SOMEHOW
THE DEMOCRATS WANT TO GET RID OF
HAMBURGER.
>> Tucker: BUT WOULDN'T YOU
SUPPORT CHANGING THE DIETARY
GUIDELINES?
REDUCE RED MEAT SPECIFICALLY?
>> YES, I WOULD.
>> Tucker: .
>> Tucker: SO KAMALA HARRIS
HAS BEEN TO GET ABOUT WHAT YOU
EAT AND SHE THINKS YOU EAT TOO
MUCH RED MEAT AND SHE CLAIMS TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT WHEN SHE
IS ELECTED GOD.
THAT AND A NUMBER OF OTHER
THINGS.
IN QUIET FACT THERE ARE QUITE A
FEW THINGS IN AMERICA THAT
KAMALA HARRIS CLAIMS TO BAN
IMMEDIATELY.
>> WOULD YOU COMMIT TO
IMPLEMENTING A FEDERAL BAN ON
TRACKING YOUR FIRST DAY IN
OFFICE?
ADDING THE UNITED STATES TO THE
LIST OF COUNTRIES THAT BANS THIS
DEVASTATING PRACTICE?
>> THERE IS NO QUESTION.
>> SO WOULD YOU BAN ON OFFSHORE
DRILLING?
>> YES.
AND AGAIN I'VE WORKED ON.
>> DO YOU BAN PLASTIC STRAWS
QUESTION MARKS TO GO I THINK
SHOULD, YEAH.
>> Tucker: BANNING DRINKING
STRAWS.
MINDLESS AND ANNOYING.
IF YOU ACTUALLY GET ABOUT
PLASTIC POLLUTION AND YOU SHOULD
CARE ABOUT PLASTIC POLLUTION,
BECAUSE IT'S HORRIFYING, YOU
WOULD PUNISH CHINA FOR JUMPING
PLASTICS INTO THE OCEAN BUT OF
COURSE NO ONE ON THE LEFT WANTS
TO DO THAT BECAUSE THEY ARE BUSY
IS SUCKING UP TO CHINA.
LOOK BANNING FRACKING IS JUST
DEMENTED.
OUR ENERGY SECTOR IS THE SINGLE
MOST SUCCESSFUL PART OF THE
ENTIRE AMERICAN ECONOMY.
IT'S ONE OF THE ONLY THING
PROPPING UP OUR TRADE BALANCE
RIGHT NOW.
IT'S BEEN A SAVER OF LAST RESORT
FOR RURAL AREAS DEVASTATED BY
GLOBALIZATION.
KAMAN HAS DIDN'T CARE ABOUT ANY
OF THAT AND SHE REALLY DOESN'T
EVEN KNOW WHEN YOUR SOUL IS DEMG
EVEN KNOW WHEN YOUR SOUL IS DEME
EVEN KNOW WHEN YOUR SOUL IS DEMB
EVEN KNOW WHEN YOUR SOUL IS DEMN
EVEN KNOW WHEN YOUR SOUL IS DEMS
EVEN KNOW WHEN YOUR SOUL IS DEMO
EVEN KNOW WHEN YOUR SOUL IS DEMN
EVEN KNOW WHEN YOUR SOUL IS DEMA
EVEN KNOW WHEN YOUR SOUL IS DEMQ
EVEN KNOW WHEN YOUR SOUL IS DEMI
EVEN KNOW WHEN YOUR SOUL IS DEMG
EVEN KNOW WHEN YOUR SOUL IS DEMA
EVEN KNOW WHEN YOUR SOUL IS DEMT
ALL COSTS, DETAILS ARE NOT
RELEVANT.
ALL YOU SEE IS YOURSELF AT THE
FINISH LINE ARMS IN THE AIR.
THIS IS A POWERFUL DRUG.
ANAND IF WE ARE BEING HONEST
ABOUT IT, HARRIS WAS NOT EVEN
CLOSE TO THE LEAST APPEALING
CANDIDATE ON THE STAGE LAST
NIGHT.
THAT AWARD GOES WITHOUT QUESTION
TO FATHER PETE BUTTIGIEG, THE
PATRON SAINT OF SOUTH BEND,
INDIANA.
FATHER BUT A JUDGE WASH INTO A
SERMON LAST MAY THAT WOULD HAVE
MADE JOHN ANNA'S JONATHAN
EDWARDS PROUD.
>> IF YOU BELIEVE THAT GOD IS
WATCHING AS POISON IS BEING
BELCHED INTO THE AIR OF CREATIO
CREATION, AND PEOPLE ARE BEING
HARMED BY, COUNTRIES ARE AT RISK
OF VANISHING AND LOW-LYING AREA
AREAS, WOODY'S EXPLICIT SUPPOSE
GOD THINKS OF THAT?
I BET HE THINKS IT'S MESSED UP.
AT LEAST ONE WAY OF TALKING
ABOUT THIS IS THAT IT'S A KIND
OF SIN.
>> Tucker: YOU STARTED TO
THINK OF THE TORMENTS WAITING
FOR YOU IN FATHER PETE'S
EPISCOPALIAN VERSION OF HELL.
IMAGINE HIM LECTURING YOU FOR
ETERNITY WAGGING HIS LITTLE
FINGERS IN YOUR FACE AND
BRAGGING ABOUT HIS VIRTUE.
THAT DOESN'T MAKE YOU WANT TO
OBEY.
FATHER PETE THOUGH THERE IS NO
SUCH JUDGMENT BECAUSE AT THE
VERY SAME TIME HE IS LECTURING
YOU FATHER PETE HIMSELF IS
LIKELY TO BE SIPPING PERRIER IN
THE GULF STREAM.
ACCORDING TO AN ASSOCIATED PRESS
REPORT, HE FLIES ON CLIMATE
DESTROYING PRIVATE JETS MORE
THAN ANY OTHER DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATE IN THE RACE RIGHT NOW.
HOW CAN THAT BE?
WE ASKED THE BUTTIGIEG CAMPAIGN
THAT QUESTION TODAY AND HERE'S
OUR RESPONSE.
>> WE FLY COMMERCIAL AS OFTEN AS
POSSIBLE AND ONLY FLY
NONCOMMERCIAL WHEN THE SCHEDULE
DICTATES.
>> Tucker: NONCOMMERCIAL.
OH, THAT MAKES SENSE.
SO WHEN IT'S CONVENIENT, FATHER
BUT A JUDGE FOLLOWS HIS OWN
COMMANDMENTS BUT THE REST OF THE
TIME WHEN IT THE SCHEDULE
DICTATES, HE IS HAPPY TO BELCH
POISON INTO THE AIR OF CREATION.
SO WHAT YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
DRINK FROM A PLASTIC STRAW,
THAT'S IMMORAL, BUT FATHER PETE
GETS TO KEEP HIS PRIVATE PLANE.
NO WONDER PEOPLE LOVE THE
CLIMATE ACTIVISM.
FOR THEM, IT'S ALL UPSIDE.
IT'S NOT SO GREAT FOR EVERYONE
ELSE UNFORTUNATELY BEARD FOR
POOR PEOPLE IN THE THIRD WORLD,
IT'S GOING TO BE ESPECIALLY
TOUGH.
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE AS MANY CHILDREN AS THEY
WOULD LIKE.
WATCH BERNIE SANDERS THIS MONEY
PAID >> WENT ON AND EDUCATING
EVERYONE ON THE NEED TO CURB
POPULATION SEEMS A REASONABLE
CAMPAIGN TO ENACT.
WOULD YOU BE COURAGEOUS ENOUGH
TO DISCUSS THIS ISSUE AND MAKE
IT A KEY FEATURE OF A PLAN TO
ADDRESS CLIMATE CATASTROPHES?
>> THE ANSWER IS YES AND THE
ANSWER HAS EVERYTHING TO DO WITH
THE FACT THAT WOMEN IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA BY THE
WAY I HAVE THE RIGHT TO CONTROL
THEIR OWN BODIES AND THEY CAN
MAKE PRODUCTIVE DECISIONS.
AND THE MEXICO CITY AGREEMENT
WHICH DENIES AMERICAN AID TO
THOSE ORGANIZATIONS AROUND THE
WORLD THAT ARE --
THAT ALLOW WOMEN TO HAVE
ABORTIONS OR EVEN GET INVOLVED
IN BIRTH CONTROL TO ME IS
TOTALLY ABSURD.
>> Tucker: A GO.
SANDERS SAYS IT RIGHT OUT LOUD.
THE AFRICANS ARE HAVING TOO MANY
BABIES.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THOSE AFRICANS HAVE MORE
ABORTIONS.
WE ARE GOING TO PAY FOR AFRICAN
ALSO BY THE WAY WE'RE GOING HAVE
TO CONTROL WHAT PEOPLE EAT,
HOW THEY TRAVEL, AND WHAT THEY
DO FOR A LIVING, WE'RE GOING TO